what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel apparently I got
a hate video made about me which is
shocking and very surprising but I will
be reacting to it today before I start
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
and ring that notification Bell that we
are going to be notified of my daily
videos also guys make sure you like the
video on your way in and sign up for our
memberships our fourth tier you get a
one-on-one call with me once a month hey
guys and welcome back
my name is Chad chat and I found another
really cool Alpha podcast oh she likes
my podcast hi it's my Alpha podcast
100 of my problems on 50 of the
population say a bunch of words that I
think make me sound smarter but in
reality have as much meaning as the
final paragraph in a research paper
basically the more Partners a woman has
oh look it's me I have a happy marriage
and so I think that's why historically
we've always protected women and like
tell them who's that who's that chick
spitting bags spitting facts like not be
outside of marriage because the bond
like the bond is so strong for women
during because we release a hormone
drink that men don't in conclusion do
not engage in the dirty and squirty a
study found that 169 11 that did the
dirtiest word before wedlock when 420
were sad mostly because during the
academic secrete hormones glue that
bonds them to their partner it is a huge
mess so ladies stop being such slow I'm
just kidding I don't have a podcast yes
but this person does and this time it's
a little different because the alpha in
question is a woman I think he speaks a
lot of Truth okay you see my dance moves
look at it I don't even don't want to
hear it oh if you sleep around that
you're like that is you know what's
crazy about that day when I was just
walking around the street and some
random person was like do you want to
talk about Andrew Tate like doing
interviews and I was like I do in fact
want to talk about like it was very
random to guys they don't want you to
know that like you age out of the dating
Marketplace so we have Friendly Fire
there's some Espionage it's kind of a
Benedict Arnold situation guys is it
just me or are the British kind of
slaying right now you're right they're
slaughtering us out there no I mean
they're killing it yes we've lost half
our men I'm gonna switch teams wait are
you betraying us losing a war is so beta
I've been shot five times I'm not gonna
be on the same side as a bunch of soy
boys I've seen a bunch of stitches to
her videos this past week but had a lot
of trouble finding her Tick Tock because
apparently they keep deleting it they
banned account number three but you
can't get rid of me baby you can't get
rid of me baby account number four yeah
I'm on account number five now
yeah account number five
um and six just in case that one goes
they also took my Instagram account
before but her YouTube is still up and
she goes back to those pearly things
which is kind of a weird contradiction
imagine you're strolling on the beach
with the weights crashing gently you
find a clam and you pry it open to find
a beautiful sparkling Pearl and then it
starts spewing misogyny at you it would
look so much misogyny it's not misogyny
I just speak facts lady ant plus plus
Pearl is my name she could have asked
this in a nicer way but I'll let you
guys know how exactly this name came to
be my name is Pearl and when I was a kid
I always heard just girly things and I
was like what if we did just pearly
things you could have asked nicer but
I'll tell you you smile more don't be
such a [ __ ] the reason that I think
feminism is a hate group because often
times the things that they advocate for
are at the cost of men I saw a lot of
people this week labeled yeah facts her
as a pick me and to everyone calling me
a pick me
I'd rather be a pick me than a skip me
so yeah
if you want to call me a pygmy call me a
pygmy bye which if you don't know what
that means it's basically a woman who
tries to separate herself and make it
clear that she's not like other girls
because other girls suck whenever I ever
said I'm not like other girls find me
this clip find me this clip short skirts
I wear t-shirts and then they say mean
things to me like you can't only wear
t-shirts and your genitals are showing
like what if you look at these titles
most of them reference modern women a
lot and in a negative way because as we
all know modern women want rights and
stuff and that's right it's not about
rights it's they want freedom without
any responsibility they want to be
better than men and they [ __ ] on men and
call them trash as a thank you at modern
women blame everyone but themselves
that's true oh my god dude do the show
that I've done for six months it's true
it is true modern women cannot be helped
to be free women put men in general okay
shout out to my title team
just come with me right over here in
Jeopardy what is jeopardy correct
the only women we like it's funny I
don't even write the titles but but I
stand on it I stand on it old-fashioned
ones that don't show their ankles and
churn butter she wears long skirts I
wear long skirts because it's 17.75.
t-shirts haven't been invented yet and
neither I mean I never said you had to
wear long skirts I never even said you
had to dress modestly I said maybe don't
sleep with the entire town or if you do
that don't be mad when guys don't want
to date you after I never said whatever
whatever find me the clip find me the
clip this video is quality audio
products at half the price of other
premium Brands without I feel like I
should get a cut of this
you're making these people make so much
money reacting to me that I feel like I
should get a cut of their ads you know
what's interesting to all the people
that will say oh she's like doing this
to be a pick me or doing this for money
you make more money selling to women so
if anything she's the pick me she's the
pick me and all of our other Alpha
podcasts there's usually one who does
all the talking and then there's the
other guy who's mostly there to just
agree with everything the other one says
you know like a true Alpha Pearl is kind
of different because she's the one who
mediates this podcast but she still
manages to be a yes person somehow
whether a boy or girl it's 100 your
responsibility what happens in your life
I just I think it's more in the girl
because we have more power yeah we have
like we have more power than men do in
every instance but it doesn't but no
that's terrified no sorry you're right
you're right actually you're correct
you're correct she'll say something and
then look around waiting for everyone
else to agree and encourage her to go on
it's like it's like a handshake
and that's what I mean kind of like a
child who forgot their lines no no
that's what you you talk and you wait to
see if anyone else has anything to okay
when you're hosting a conversation you
might make a statement and sometimes
it's a bold statement and so you might
say something see if anyone has anything
else to say and if they don't you keep
going because that's your job as a host
to facilitate the conversation if you
actually started a podcast you would
know but you didn't so let's play and on
that night there were and there were
three wise men there were three wise men
and then Mary gave birth to baby Jesus
good yes and because Mary got pregnant
out of wedlock you're doing great she
has zero societal value
that's funny
that's very a zero societal value
that was funny that was funny I didn't
want females with a body cap
wait but Mary was still a virgin
okay I I went to Catholic school so that
argument wouldn't make sense but it's
okay as a single mother she would have a
hard time back then getting remarried
I'm pretty sure they're about to stick
her ass if Joseph didn't like take her
but what I guess for this isn't
historical that was funny I'll give you
that one that was funny
[Applause]
who do you call to get your car fixed a
man or a woman so I fixed my own car
only men can be mechanics everyone sorry
okay I want to look up I'm about to do
this on my phone what percent of
mechanics are women 3.6 of all mechanics
are women so when you call to get your
car fixed who do you call most likely a
man it's not to say that women can't be
mechanics but it's to say that women
don't want to be mechanics and if you
watch the full podcast you would know do
a woman job like read from iPad or be
named after slimy thing a mollusk makes
I can I can do it hey hey I was named
after the from SpongeBob thank you very
much
the power your power supply who runs it
who runs the infrastructure of society
men or women and this is the whole point
being single being a single woman is a
privilege in society normally in society
you would need a man to protect you and
we still are using men as a group to
protect us and to run the infrastructure
of society who is in charge of the
infrastructure the power lines who is in
charge of the freaking Plumbing who is
in charge of the electricity it's men or
by and large men occasionally there are
women that do it but it's the exception
it's not the norm and the thing is a lot
of times we don't have any appreciation
for the fact that men built the world
and allow us to live in it anyways but
they'll probably whatever actually what
she's saying is that we need the
patriarchy because the patriarchy said
we need the patriarchy God that's not
what I whatever whatever it seems
trustworthy he runs the infrastructure
of society men or women we know who's in
charge of more things and who has been
no no is that who's in charge of more
things it's who wants to do the hard
jobs do you want to be a garbage man no
I don't want to do it you want to be a
mechanic no do you want to do the
hardest jobs in society no you want to
go work in an oil rig I don't it's not
it's not the patriarchy oh boohoo my
life is so hard I don't get to work on
an oil rig stop it fan stop it you
wouldn't do that even if you could
historically that's kind of the problem
just because you're named after the
byproduct of an oyster doesn't mean you
have to have the same thought process
hey the from SpongeBob thank you Pearl
initially blew up because of this Tick
Tock which I'm gonna put a big old
warning and time stamp over because what
did I initially use this garbage I don't
blame you name one girl that looks good
at 300 pounds
300 is a lot I don't care what anyone
says 300 is a lot of weight I didn't say
220. I didn't say 200 I said 300 pounds
do you do you think you want to keep
them fat so you don't have to compete
with them yeah some girls I swear to God
I stand on that I stand on that they're
like oh you look great sis but they only
say that so they can look better stop it
I'll tell you the truth no one looks
good at 300 pounds and I stand on that
for you there's a lot of girls and
that's not what made me blow up
initially what blew up my channel was a
video I did with my friend Jess called I
showed my friend the red pill for the
first time that was like the turning
point in my channel this is just where
the libs found me Plumping themselves up
right now I'm motivating them to get on
the treadmill look at it if you love
someone you tell them the truth I've
gotten messages say
it say I started to lose weight because
of your comments not only is she an
adult iPad kid she's also a fat phobic
adult iPad kid I'm gonna be talking
about it's okay it's not even an iPad
it's a laptop that folds attack part two
for talking about and you're still awake
she refers to plus-sized people as
whales yeah multiple times on her
account because she just cannot stop
thinking about the ocean it's ingrained
and her gas those are beautiful majestic
creatures they are beautiful majestic
creatures for a pod brain she hasn't had
a Krabby Patty in years
I know it's not even funnier than I'm
named it no actually okay my mom didn't
actually name me after the from
SpongeBob but I thought it was funny I
think she had a neighbor named Pearl
homesick
I said name one girl that looks good at
300 pounds she uploaded a 10 minute
response to everyone being reasonably
upset with her and does anyone want to
guess what her defense of this clip was
you're not gonna get it it's totally
original for an alpha podcast we've
never heard anyone say this before on
Tick Tock a clip was taking taken of me
it was a bit out of context you know
sometimes maybe I make fun of them a
little too hard I gave you the price
sometimes I could be wrong maybe I take
it too far but I stand on it I stand on
it next okay I was about to be upset and
act like words have meaning or something
hey 300 is a lot so do you notice how
she's not 300 pounds go beat 300 pounds
see if you like the way you look Alice
can I ask you something hey look at look
at guys guys smash or pass girl at 300
pounds Kobe pass pass and blessing what
about what about 250 smash or pass pass
pass
I'm just say ask the men the majority of
men ain't trying to screw they ain't
even trying to screw girls at 300 pounds
much less wife um so stupid and ugly
what the hell that was literally out of
context calm down okay never mind I
think you're a stinky piece of garbage
and I hope Josh leaves you at the altar
is this still out of three hundreds a
lot that's a lot of ways obviously yes
what were you gonna ask me do you want
to be my maid of honor oh my God yes I
would love to this is so great she's
also drinking about 14 drinks during
this video and keeps pausing to take
sips
I guess she's
[Laughter]
I do I do I do like a variety when it
comes to my drinks graded from being so
salty all the time I don't I don't
really mind being made fun of I feel
like it's part of the game I feel like
like okay
yeah okay I'll tell you my drink variety
so I'll do a water and either a coffee
or a tea sometimes both occasionally a
smoothie that's my kryptonite is sugar
drinks I won't lie to you I love sugar
drinks but not enough to get to 300
pounds that's the whole point that's the
whole point
[Music]
I don't know if they're supposed to make
this seem like more of a casual little
Vlog but it's not translating that way I
know you're all insulting me I mean it
wasn't honestly I'll tell you what it is
I'm lazy and so if I can just pull it on
my phone and do a video rather than pull
up a cannon where I have to take out the
SD card upload it to my computer it's
just less work to just upload it
straight from us she doesn't really care
does she because I insulted you first
but I could not care less
obviously she has low self-esteem and oh
my God this is what they always do they
try to psychoanalyze me internalize me a
lot of it psychologically she is
constipated but so is everyone else okay
we're all constipated in our hearts just
go to therapy or take it or go to
therapy I mean I just want something
more original from these people it's
always you're so insecure I liked the
Virgin Mary that was creative okay I
thought that was a very good roast but
when you're like you're too insecure go
to therapy it's just like come up with
something better anyway anyway and how
does that make you feel shitty like I
think if a woman cheats she's trying to
leave you if a man yes yes yes just like
it's getting it's like a handshake
why is the exposure turned all the way
up in these clips we need to get their
editor over to the house of dragons team
we can't see we must incest you turn the
brightness up you can absolutely sleep
with a woman who you may find very
attractive and very sexy and everything
else but your heart is still completely
with another woman
okay I wonder if this guy has ever
cheated on a partner before do you think
he's cheated on a partner before because
I don't think he has your honor really
when you think about it as a man I am
biologically prone to setting that
building on fire now if I were a woman
then this would be arson yes but when I
do it it's just like lighting birthday
candles pink women are just see
that's what that I mean I never condone
cheating I don't think cheating's okay
but what I don't do is go to the world
and tell it how to be and throughout all
of history more women have reproduced
than men and powerful men have cheated
and I can't I can't change what the
world is so do I think men and women are
different yeah is cheating different for
men and for women yeah do I condone it
no these these emotional yes like like
you know women are more likely to wage
war
how were there statistics for things
that haven't happened Pearl you can't
just be like well yeah Queens out of the
last 500 years look it up researchers
from the University of Chicago studied
European rulers from 1480 to 1913 and
found that European queens were 27 more
likely to wage war than Kings with
married Queens being the most likely to
go to battle
anyways technically hasn't happened but
if it did this is definitively how it
would like percentage-wide like I know
more men have because more men have been
in power but women are actually more
likely to do it when they're in power
What percentages you can't just 27 we
can play
27 specifically
warmongering female leaders can be found
throughout history and across the globe
from bodica to Catherine 2 of Russia to
renavala I'm pronouncing these names
wrong ranavala won the Mad queen of
Madagascar
um the Celtic Queen of the iseni tribe
letters Vault against Rome in 6061 A.D
that left 80 000 Roman citizens of
Britain dead 27 more likely if you're
wondering and typically back a
hypothetical let's take your theory and
apply it to this diagram here so first
identify the problem women obviously
number two collect data this one's a
little difficult because you don't
[ __ ] have any and three create Harry
Potter
the University of Chicago that's a
pretty smart school so do women start
wars have women worn Wars vinville women
say yes to war where Wars like I feel
like a lot of problems would be solved
if literally we got rid of birth control
on social media what do you think is the
biggest challenge for women when it
comes to social media and what they see
on a daily basis
um I think it inflates like women's ego
so like I think a lot of times we think
we're hotter than we are I don't know if
they don't have Wi-Fi in bikini bottom
but this is famously the opposite effect
of social media are you saying that you
scroll through Instagram just thinking
to yourself you know I was feeling
pretty self-conscious but now that I've
seen all of these unattainable beauty
standards I'm feeling a lot better I
think it inflates like women's ego no
matter what they're saying they use this
same Sad Piano track in the background
of every YouTube show I think that
modern women are
that's true I don't edit these myself
but
yeah yeah he does and they don't even
pay for it you can hear the watermark
playing over and over and over the whole
point is that while Instagram may give
women insecurities right and encourage
women to get things like plastic surgery
the point is that an average chick can
get dm'd by a multi-billionaire
multi-millionaire whatever it is the the
hottest guy in her town and he's just
trying to use her first but she thinks
she's on that level and you get this
because you have girls on my show that
come on and have these delusional
unrealistic standards and it's like
where does this come from why does it
every girl that I interview what do you
rank yourself one to ten ten ten ten I
mean you get the occasional seven but if
they say seven they're usually four
women can camouflage their entire bodies
like chameleons and they communicate
with satellite dishes that pop out of
their and if you don't believe me I'm
going to repeat the same thing but with
Piano Sonata number nine in F major
women can camouflage their entire body I
mean honestly it sounds good with the
piano
[Music]
in
contradiction
generally narcissists and they're the
first woman in I think probably most of
history that they tend to destroy what
they love and Chase what they hate are
we certain that you're describing women
and not one of the villains from
Scooby-Doo and I would have gotten away
with it too if it wasn't for those
meddling Alphas with their sure sm7bs
thank you
perhaps a number of things they want but
generally I think the modern woman
doesn't want to love I think the modern
woman wants to feel more than anything
she doesn't want to love she wants to
feel because love isn't a feeling
anymore I guess I like how they talk
about women as if they're love that's
that's the whole point and see she just
proved my point right there modern women
think love is a feeling but it is a
choice do you think that someone that
was married for 50 70 years every day
felt like they were in love no it's a
choice but modern women think it's a
feeling you just proved my entire point
my entire Point like this is why men and
women are having a harder time getting
together because we are sold this Disney
fairy detail that is not true entirely
different species even Pearl they act
like they have women in glass cages that
they've been studying test subject three
zero zero eight no you don't need glass
cages when women come on social media
and do the work for them they do the
work for you because they come on social
media and expose themselves like you did
right there still maintaining the sleep
schedule of an anxious barn owl subject
constantly complains about recurring
sharp pain in random parts of body but
would rather tempt death and drive to a
dog it would be more like subject came
on a public platform it said men are
trash men are the problem blah blah blah
blah that would be more accurate but
there's office subject also continues I
don't really give a [ __ ] about your
sleep schedule I'm sorry eat a bowl of
birth control and milk every morning
while reciting some sort of ritualistic
chance
driving to my house in the middle I mean
most virtually all women in the western
world now
under a certain age are modern women to
various degrees modern women are
feminists I guess he's explaining how
women are feminists some adopted all
wholesale some are more resistant but
overall it's influenced and permeated
through Society over the last few days
did you say permeated are you making
Mead most yeah zubi does use some big
words sometimes I'm like I don't even
know what he's saying I mean virtually
all women in society are women in
society to various degrees and I tend to
believe that women are kind of fermented
in their spirits and keeping this in
mind is this a filibuster guys no I'm
not gonna lie she's entertaining she's
funny she's funny I'm not even mad come
on I hardly know her she's happily he's
happier in his relationship when he's at
eight or nine yeah I attested that I
think the more women The more I've
worked out what it is I want what I
don't want it left me in a position
where I knew exactly what I wanted what
was completely non-negotiable so
essentially you have a love life and it
helps you understand what you like or
don't like in bed and eventually it
helps you understand what you're looking
for in a partner and leads to long-term
happiness in a relationship if you're a
guy sorry did you think I was no if
you're not a guy you lose actually the
highest marital rates are when they're
both virgins so I just like to throw
that in there 25 of your value every
time it passes you in the street usually
in a time of Crisis that's when our
natural selves come out that's why when
crisis hits women start to do household
chores
back
maybe I should I should ask anyone want
anything to eat other guys guys face
consequences for their decisions like
that's the whole point is like sure like
like men when they make a bad decision
they always have a consequence women
don't this is also true my period
started yesterday so I waged war in
France I just told them that my tummy
hurt and they forgave me and that's why
women are aware yeah we could compare
periods to I don't know men being
homeless committing getting divorced and
getting half their [ __ ] taken
um losing access to their children yeah
you're right it's the same periods yeah
Pearl you're supposed to at least
pretend you're not a terrible thing in
person you're not playing by the Alpha
Rules well sorry it's not you take away
consequences for one gender they're
going to act worse I think it would be
the same if men had no consequences for
anything women don't have consequences
men do so forgot we have no consequences
so it doesn't I guess yeah we're bailed
out of every bad decision we make
everyone if we want to sleep around
there's birth control if we get pregnant
we have abortion if we want to keep the
kid we can divorce our husband or put
him on child support if we want to get
married we can get divorced if we get
we're bad with our money there's
government assistance that men mostly
pay into if we're bad with our money
there are women's shelters there's no
men's shelters there's violence against
women we never talk about violence
against men so yeah we're bailed out
pretty much every bad decision men get
three times the amount of sentencing for
the same crime the same crime Alpha
Rules don't apply to us men when they
make a bad decision they have the
consequence immediately where women
don't so this has honestly been really
freeing guys I all this time I've been
trying to be a good person and do nice
things for people when I could have been
doing whatever I want
which is bad things bad
[Music]
foreign
there guys thank you for subscribing and
if you are okay so final thoughts I
actually thought that was a very
entertaining video I was actually a bit
impressed with the editing and I liked
the hate I liked my first hate video I
thought it was cool I mean she got a
couple things wrong as the haters do but
overall I'm gonna give this hate video
an 8 out of 10. good job don't forget to
like the video on your way out subscribe
to the channel ring that notification
Bell and I will talk to you next time as
many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible